tell me about now this is live action
some of its animated some of its CGI are
we gonna see you only animated are you
one of be wearing a pregnant belly
I am always animated okay so there's
really very little difference between
that in real life for me how excited are
you to be a part of this film and did
you ever play Sonic growing up like I
did I did
I did stumble on it a couple of times I
was never a big video game guy but now
obviously I'm gonna lie and say I am you
loved it you grew up with it this is the
best this is 20 this year celebrates 25
years of a year that you can't even
believe happened the same movies came
out all in one year Ace Ventura the mass
Dumb and Dumber 25 years of that iconic
character repeat what are you bring it
back what am i bring it back oh I'm
bringing nothing back no no no no I'm
moving forward I mean a lot to you the
only thing is like you get a lot of
pressure from people you know to bring
things back and stuff and then you do
and they go okay I just wanted you to do
something you know I'm doing tons yeah
yeah but all new all new well now you're
adding I noticed you know I follow you
on Twitter and I noticed a small mistake
in your Twitter feed it says you know
official Twitter of actor Jim Carrey but
now it's actor artiste
yeah well I wouldn't pronounce it that
way but but yeah you know things are
happy you know the creativity it just
kind of spills over the edges and
there's these different kind of modes
try to catch it
Whoopi there's really little difference
for me right between doing a painting or
a sculpture and and doing an acting part
so you're you're sculpting from the
inside out you always had the artistic
like painting sculpting as a part of you
since you're a kid yeah it's you know I
spent a lot of time in my room
a lot of time with my sketching and
stuff like that I want some art
exhibitions when I was a little kid and
I always had a talent for it so yeah it
was a wonderful refuge for me you know
against whatever right I guess I was
born in Vietnam so during that era not
in the actual place how much is a Jim
Carey original going for these days like
if I wanted to buy one can I afford it
ROC price with you know I don't talk
price for two I don't have enough money
right I have older people doing that
sort of thing we're in Las Vegas tell me
are you a guy that likes to go are you a
foodie when you have free time here do
you want to go eats do you wanna gamble
do you want to see a show that's the one
thing I love about this place is that
the food is fantastic here now you know
you got everybody from all walks of life
you know throwing their best at it so
it's fantastic I'm not a big gambler you
know the last time I played blackjack I
was up ten grand and then the dude with
the clipboard came out and ruined my
vibe completely and that's what they do
watch out when the guy with the
clipboard comes out tip the dealer and
leave
[Music]
[Applause]